bonsoir christophe lèguevaques merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france on imagine ce soir votre
déception voire votre incompréhension
incompréhension non déception
certainement mais ce n'est que partie
remise puisque nous aurons certainement
aller un appel pour expliquer encore un
peu plus un petit peu plus mieux aux
magistrats pourquoi il est nécessaire
que les citoyens en quête de leur propre
initiative et n'attendent pas que des
commissions parlementaires ou de vagues
d'instruction se suivent leur cours les
citoyens que je représente les
associations je représente pose un
certain nombre de questions qui sont
entremêlées en quelque sorte et qui
comme le point de départ la question des
masques qui ont manqué cruellement dans
les hôpitaux et dans les états ce qui a
contraint les pouvoirs publics au
printemps dernier c'était il ya un an je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez à faire
ce qu'on a appelé un tri des malades et
les personnes qui avaient un certain âge
on leur refusait l'accès à l'hôpital
si c'est vrai il faut qu'on trouve les
traces de ces manquements et dernier
élément dans les ehpad avec des
personnes âgées et malades
la solution qu'ils ont trouvée c'est de
faire appel à un produit qu'on appelle
le rivotril qui en fait est un moyen de
tana zié ça me dire les personnes qu'on
ne savait pas soigné et bien là encore
on veut réunir un certain nombre de
pièces et d'information pour ensuite
attaquer qu'il appartiendra ça peut être
aussi bien les pas d'un question que les
médecins traitants ou la rs ou ads et on
se réserve même la possibilité de
remonter dès comme istres c'est vrai
qu'à elle estimé
d'une part cette association ne s'était
pas positionné assez clairement sur la
nature de l'action que y avait déjà eu
des auditions c'est vrai qu'on en a
suivi pas bah là devant les
parlementaires au sénat ou à l'assemblée
nationale que d'autre part les ministres
étaient déjà poursuivis pour certains
devant la cour de justice ça veut dire
que que vous et surtout vos clients
n'ont pas eu assez de réponses à cette
occasion notamment lors de ses auditions
publiques
si vous voulez les auditions publiques
ce le point de départ de l'enquète on a
des témoignages de syndicalistes
notamment qui nous explique dans les
ehpad
il s'est passé des choses qui sont
critiquables maintenant on valeo 2
d'une simple affirmation de principe on
veut aller dans des cas particuliers
pour chercher des responsabilités des
hommes et des autres puis il n'y a pas
que les pouvoirs publics y aussi une
enquête nous on mène 2 qui l'intéressent
au premier plan qui concerne les grande
distribution le 4 mai 2001 leclerc et
carrefour annoncé que chacun avait
commandé 250 millions notre 150 millions
de masques qu'ils allaient les
commercialiser la question toute simple
que l'on pose c'est de savoir quand ces
masques sont ils arrivés en france et en
fonction de la réponse nous sera donné
on se réserve la possibilité de
poursuivre ou pas ces entreprises parce
que s'ils ont reçu fin avril début mai
pas de problème en revanche ils ont reçu
fin mars qu'ils ont gardé pendant tout
le mois d'avril en stock pour spéculer
sur la vie l'amour des gens là je pense
que nous allons les poursuivre et
curieusement il refuse de répondre à
cette question très simple à quelle date
les masses sont ils arrivés sur le
territoire français alors c'est vrai
qu'à vous entendre les questions sont
pour le moins d'une gravité assez
exceptionnel on a tous entendu des
témoignages très durs sur des proches
des familles qui ont perdu leurs proches
lors de cette crise
est-ce qu'elle n'est pas un type europe
démocratique cette décision de la part
du tribunal judiciaire de paris est
plutôt étonnante quand même payer parce
que ce terrain le juge a fait simplement
l'application de la règle de droit à sa
manière il a considéré que lire les
demandeurs n'était pas de dispositif de
l'intérêt légitime pour poser les
questions parce qu'ils estiment ces sons
c'est son choix ses décisions que les
enquêtes qui sont en cours sont
suffisantes
nous pensons que sont largement
insuffisantes et notamment elle pêche de
pour la raison suivante c'est qu'elles
sont confidentielles on n'a pas accès à
l'information qui est qui est menée et
donc nous nous voulons peser l'impôt de
vue démocratique d'un point de vue
citoyen sur les enquêtes en cours pour
justement faire toute la lumière sur ce
qui s'est passé
peut-être d'ailleurs sur une lumière qui
rassurera les citoyens ou alors ça ne
pète ça mettra en évidence des
comportements délictueux et dans ce cas
là nous poursuivrons tous les
responsables
je ne m'adresse pas judiciaire de paris
mais confidentiel
mais est ce possible dans un état de
droit que ce type de documents restent
confidentielles vu encore une fois la
gravité exceptionnelle ce qui est
confidentielle celle enquête c'est à
dire que nous sommes à une phase
d'instruction
et comme vous le savez il existe ce
qu'on appelle le secret de l'instruction
vingt sept cas d'un ce cadre là tout ce
que toutes les enquêtes que même le juge
d'instruction sont couverts par ce
secret s'est créé par la loi c'est ça
doit avoir au moins 200 ans
donc y'a rien d'anormal là dessus
simplement on ne sait pas dans quelle
direction ils cherchent et la vente de
notre procédure s'était justement de
permettre à des citoyens de peser sur le
cours des enquêtes et d'orienter un des
directions qui ne sont pas forcément
celles qui sont suivies vous êtes des
exemples de la grande distribution
il y avait d'autres exemples concernant
par exemple des grandes entreprises de
ti gère les ehpad pour mettre en
évidence le fait qu'elle préfère
améliorer leur rentabilité interne ces
entreprises plutôt que de satisfaire les
besoins sanitaires des résidents donc là
il ya une enquête qui est peut-être très
large mais qui est nécessaire parce que
la crise du coc vide a mis en évidence
des malfaçons des problèmes qui sont
sujettes à présent tenu sous le boisseau
et il est indispensable que les citoyens
s'en saisissent et inédit reviennent au
secours d'une représentation nationale
donc d'un parlement qui est trop souvent
aux ordres du gouvernement et qui ne
fait pas son travail jusqu'au bout
christophe lèguevaques avocat au barreau
de paris d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france